to give you an idea of how much work it
takes to to look like daniel does in the
movies we ask the audience if they
happen to have any shots of themselves
emerging from the waves
sadly some did
actually i i say sadly now the first one
rather where's where's a glenn
now look at glenn
now
was this a long time ago this picture
just saying uh look at glenn
look at that
look he's getting around applause for
everybody wow
are you an actor
what do you do uh lawyer he's a lawyer a
beautiful lawyer look at him
where's uh kerry barnes where's kerry
there's kerry now is tom here
he is oh you're tom hello now tom he
took a lovely picture of himself he
liked the picture so much is this true
he gave it to you for christmas in a
frame
and where does he make you keep it
it's beside the bed so you can look at
it when uh all right we understand
well there it is
[Applause]
and finally
our final bathing beauty is uh steve
steve oh there's steve steve now uh
steve well steve went a bit he likes
just getting out of the way seen a full
photo shoot uh here he is just in
general here i am getting out of the
waves
that's a very odd print on those talks
that's all i'll all say there but he
sort of pulls that off he's sort of you
know
he looks quite manish
and some of the other shots he doesn't
quite carry it off as well
[Applause]
and then
then it must have been a long day of
shooting and he just went model crazy
oh yeah
oh tiger
[Applause]
[Music]
you